how did you get into acting did you
always want to do it because when you're
that young
i don't know did you just get the bug
for it or so my mom and my sister
were were actors um and i guess i used
to like unbuckle myself and try and
crash their auditions
but then there was one moment my
sister's 13 years older than me she's
like my best friend
and she was auditioning for a movie and
they came out and they saw me and they
said does your little sister act and
they said i don't know
they said she want to audition and so i
they looked at me i was like okay
i couldn't read or anything i say it's
such a god thing and then from that
point on it just
it just started so fortunate for it yeah
and that's kind of cool having a
13 she was 13 years older yeah and now
she has two little girls so i'm
exactly the same age difference to them
so i'm always like this is a way for me
to thank you for being a good sister
because
now i get to give it back like that's so
cool yeah it's like you've got two mamas
yeah
yeah which is kind of annoying maybe
sometimes
but yep i'm still here just waiting for
you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever